Dangerous people are
indoctrinated in your children.
That's according to a leading conservative
who is warning parents in a new video
about sending their kids to
America's liberal colleges.
You're supporting ideologues who
claimed that all truth is subjective,
that all sex differences are socially
constructed and that Western imperialism
is the sole source of
all third world problems.
The man in that video,
Dr. Jordan Peterson is with us right now.
He's a University of Toronto,
psychology professor and
author of the world hit book.
It's called 12 rules for life,
an antidote to crisis,
which has spoken to so many people.
Uh,
Dr. Peterson,
we thank you very much for
joining us live in that,
in that introduction you say,
uh,
I go to you is saying there are
dangerous people teaching your children.
Who are you talking about?
Well,
increasingly and this is normally
the case in the universities,
people are being taught by ideologues
north by educators and idiot logs have a
very simple way of looking at the world.
They reduce it to a few
principals like inequality,
unfairness and power.
Those would be the fundamental principles
at the moment that are operating on
the radical left and they're
on an ideological campaign.
And that's increasingly
the case in in elementary,
junior high and high schools as well.
Mostly because the faculties of education
are full of people who were radical.
So on.
This is well documented.
I mean even the chronicle of higher
education came out a month ago with a,
with a blistering piece on faculties
of education describing them is
academically suspect and
ideologically possessed,
which I think is exactly right.
Well we've talked a lot about
that on this program and,
but the,
the question is four for appearance,
who are thinking about sending their kids
to college someday or already have is,
is this effort rather than these uh,
professors and whatnot being
educators but being law,
where'd that come from?
Is it a concerted across the board thing
or is it just happening by accident?
I don't know.
I think part of it,
part of it's still a hangover
from the 1960s I would say,
and perhaps even a bit of a
hangover from the cold war.
What do you mean?
You mean the people from the sixties
and seventies are now and the ethos that
that that was,
that was broadcast so widely in the 1960s
and there was a lot of stress in the
60s especially because of the Vietnam
war and the consequences of the ongoing
called Warren.
We're still sort of suffering from the
aftermath of that ideological battle,
but I also think the university's made
a dreadful mistake expanding their
humanities per view to include disciplines
like women's studies and these ethnic
studies disciplines,
which aren't disciplines.
They're pseudo disciplines I
have passed and they have very,
very low academic standards and they're
corrupting the rest of the enterprise.
And so,
and that's,
that's not a good thing.
What do you mean corrupting
the rest of the enterprise?
Well,
you need to have standards in education.
And the fact that disciplines emerged
that have no real methodology and no
method of proof,
no philosophical background,
no real history meant that and that they
became degree granting enterprises and
that they,
that they emerge to produce
political activists,
which is exactly what they
advertise on their websites,
means that you've got to,
like,
you've got a fifth column of video logs
operating behind the scenes and all
they,
there,
they spend almost all of their
time engaged in political activism,
you know,
and,
and that's not good for the university
as a whole or any stretch or biases or
for society as a whole.
Well,
Jordan,
if,
if somebody is thinking about
sending their kids at college,
I've put three through good schools,
uh,
what should they know about
where they send their kids?
I mean,
it's not like you have a
big choice because a lot of
the people in positions of
power in education are
to the political left.
I mean,
that's just a fact.
You can go and you could go look
up the heterodox academy on online.
That's run by Jonathan Heit,
Hu,
Hu Hu,
or he's a main player in it at that he's
here in New York and he's tried to rank
order universities by their adherence
to truth rather than social justice and
put University of Chicago
at the top of the list,
for example.
And I think increasingly that parents
and students will wise up and start,
start,
uh,
not tending may universities that are
basically playing an ideological game.
What is the matter with having people
from the ideological left to being your
children's instructors though?
I mean,
Jose late.
It depends on how you want
all sides of the equation.
You want to know all the opinions.
Well,
yes you do.
But there's,
there's no evidence that the middle of
the road or the conservative side of the
PA or the opinion spectrum
is being represented in the
humanities and the social
studies.
That's your worry if that,
and the fact that there's
something to be said for the left,
but there's not very much to
be said for the radical left.
And that distinction isn't being made
and the left can clearly go too far as it
did many times in the 20th century.
And so when it gets too radical,
especially when there's no countering
voices and there are very few,
then that's a bad,
that's a bad thing.
It's bad for education.
It's bad for broader society.
It's,
it's,
it's altogether bad.
Right?
Jordan,
you've been around the
world talking your book up.
Uh,
you know,
people stop you on the
street all the time.
Now,
what's the one thing you have learned
since your book a 12 rules for life and
antidote to chaos came out.
How has the response been
and how has it impacted you?
Who,
well,
there's,
I've learned two things.
I've learned that people are starving
for a real conversation about
responsibility and meaning and about the
relationship between those two things.
Because people need us
sustaining meaning in their life.
And it's not to be found through
rights and impulsive gratification.
It's to be found through the
adoption of responsibility.
That's the first thing.
And the second thing is that people
are a lot smarter than we think.
So if you allow them
longform dialogue time,
even in public lectures,
there's a huge market for it.
There's a huge hunger for it,
podcasts and,
and the,
and the new video that's emerging online
with these long form discussions is
that people are smarter
than we thought and more,
and people can listen to
very complex material.
So that's,
that's a really positive thing.
Right.
Well,
it's always a pleasure.
Thank you very much.
Thanks very much for the,
and it's actually going
to be on PBS very shortly.
And of course the big book
is called 12 rules for life.
It's a worldwide bestseller.
Dr. Jordan Peterson.
Thank you,
sir.
Thanks very much.